hello everybody and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll few years ago
I was being interviewed on camera for a
TV show a documentary about physics and
we were talking about black holes and
crazy things about quantum mechanics and
some speculative ideas and during a
break the director said to me I love
doing shows on this kind of topic but my
brain always hurts it's just so hard to
think about this stuff and I said
immediately now you know how I feel
every day that's what I do for a living
when I'm not podcasting I'm thinking
about theoretical physics and crazy
ideas and physics works at the
boundaries of what we know physics is
driven by puzzles and mysteries by
things that we don't yet understand if
we're lucky those puzzles come from
experiments we'd get some data that we
can't fit together that doesn't quite
make sense in our current conception so
we try to improve our theories but
sometimes we have two theories that
individually make perfect sense but
don't fit together that is the case with
perhaps the single biggest looming
question in modern theoretical physics
how we reconcile quantum mechanics our
best theory of how the world works at a
fundamental level especially at the
level of tiny particles in the subatomic
realm and gravity the theory that is
explained by Albert Einstein's theory of
general relativity the idea that space
and time are curved what we want is to
fit them together to have a theory of
quantum gravity that somehow the world
is fundamentally quantum mechanical and
it gives rise to curved space-time that
we notice as gravity the problem is you
try to do that using the techniques that
work for other theories of physics you
quantize general relativity and it
doesn't seem to work so for decades now
physicists have been trying to ask how
do we find a quantum theory of gravity
one of the world's biggest experts in
this field is today's guest Carlo
Rovelli dr. rivela is a professor at if
I can say this correctly the South pas
de physique Theory illumina of X
Marseille University in France although
he's originally Italian as he will
explain Carlo was a bit of a
arouser as a youth he has that fiery
Italian temperament but these days he
works on reconciling Albert Einstein's
general relativity with the principles
of quantum mechanics along the way dr.
rivela has written several books his
2014 book seven brief lessons in physics
was a runaway New York Times bestseller
he just has a book that came out called
the order of time on the nature of time
and therefore of course space time which
is important for understanding quantum
gravity the latest news I heard was that
the audiobook version of the order of
time is going to be read by the actor
Benedict Cumberbatch as a fellow book
author who has to read his own books
this makes me very jealous but what
we'll talk about with dr. rivela is the
subject of quantum gravity as I alluded
to given something that we think we
understand electromagnetism or the
nuclear forces there's a cookbook
procedure for taking that classical
theory and quantizing it it breaks down
when you try to do this for gravity so
what do you do this is a big topic in
theoretical physics today the most
popular answer as you may have heard of
something called string theory it grew
directly out of particle physics just by
saying that we should replace the idea
of little point particles being the most
fundamental ingredients of nature with
little pieces of vibrating string that
sounds like a crazy speculative idea but
it leads you directly to predict the
existence of gravity so who knows it
seems to be very promising but it hasn't
exactly let us say to be very modest
about it explained all the things we
want to explain about the universe so
dr. reveille is a champion of a
different perspective called loop
quantum gravity he was one of the
originators of this idea it's relatively
straightforward in its approach it says
take general relativity we know what
that is Einstein gave it to us and maybe
the reason why it fails when we try to
straightforwardly quantize it it's just
that we're not quite clever enough maybe
there is a not quite straightforward way
of taking general relativity and
plugging it into the rules of quantum
mechanics so loop quantum gravity right
now is sort of a plucky minority
point of view it's not nearly as popular
as string theory is but to be very fair
we don't know what is right it's
certainly a respectable thing and given
that we don't know the answer it's
important that we pursue lots of
different possibilities
maybe it's the going to be the case that
some hybrid version of both string
theory and loop quantum gravity will
eventually turn out to be right maybe
the techniques from one will be very
useful in the other one
I asked carlo about this in the podcast
interview and he immediately slapped me
down he was not in favor of the idea
that string theory loop quantum gravity
will be someday reconciled but he's also
a fair guy he knows that we have to keep
an open mind about these things since we
don't know how to quantize gravity
perhaps it comes down to taste in the
sense of there's different important
principles of quantum mechanics of
gravity that somehow have to be
reconciled some of them are going to go
some of them are going to be preserved
which ones are most important that's why
it's important that we have different
people working on different approaches
because we don't yet know which one is
going to be correct so solving the
biggest outstanding puzzle in
theoretical physics today
that's our podcast topic let's go
[Music]
carlo rovelli
welcome to the mindscape podcast Thank
You Sean it's very good
yeah very great to have you here we're
both at a conference on the nature of
time and the observer so I'm taking the
opportunity to sit down with one of the
world's experts in quantum gravity and
have a chat fantastic
so why don't we start just with you
explaining to the audience because it's
hopefully a broad audience and they
might not be physics aficionados just
who you are how you got to be where you
are what your interests are very briefly
I am Italian I started my life in Korea
in Italy in physics sort of late because
I was not a nerd that school focused on
science I was interested in everything I
moved to United States it was a faculty
in America for about 10 years and I
moved back to France I'm now living in
France and quantum gravity has been my
interest my focus my passion and my
obsession all through my life all
through your life all through your life
at well from from the moment I got
interested to this was there a thing
that got you yes I I first first like I
sort of got in love with quantum
mechanics and general relativity when I
studied these things I said wow this is
incredible this is the world is
different than what we think and it is
marvelous and then I was a student I
stumbled upon a review paper by Chris I
Shama it's London physicists at the time
there were very few people who were
interested in quantum gravity so what
year are we talking um 76 78 something
like that and the Chris I said was a
little bit of the Guru of quantum
gravity at the time and he had this
fantastic review paper which he was
explaining the problem and I read it I
didn't understand much of course but it
said space and time are not what you
think they are even after I stand even
after one
mechanics and more to that it said space
and time we don't yet know well yeah
we're not sure what they are and here is
a fantastic open problem the core of
modern physics we don't understand the
basic grammar of the universe and I say
wow this is what I want to do the rest
of my life
and actually I did very good I mean I
think that we can all agree the
reconciliation of quantum mechanics and
gravity is one of the great challenges
of modern physics right now it has been
for quite a while let's get there sort
of by starting with explaining quantum
mechanics and explaining gravity maybe
gravity is is easier to do first so well
yes is hard well we will have a
discussion great is sort of easier
Gradius is is a what to understand about
gravity is a stroke of genius by
Einstein them that he can he got between
1910 and 1915 and what happened is this
that Newton had introduced this idea of
a space in which we live and and an
absolute time which passes independently
of of everything which was a newtonian
idea it's not an older idea because
before him er a space was just sort of
how things are ordered who is next to
whom and time was just sort of counting
things that happen yeah right so day
night day night and you count them 1 2 3
that's time which means that if nothing
happens there's no time right but Newton
introduces Eddy other time is time by
itself and space is space by itself is
there even there is nothing else and I
sign that the at 10 years earlier had
figured out to a special activity that
space and time you can view them pretty
much in a single thing that today we
call Minkowski space-time which is a
sort of background of the world on on
which thing thinks things have all think
happened a nice thing was fascinated by
Maxwell's
my little magnetism which was not very
old at his time because it was about 30
40 years old something like that so much
less older than what generally we think
what the mechanics are for today so
Maxwell put together electricity
magnetism into electromagnetism roughly
1860s 1860s yeah and so Einstein is
thinking turn-of-the-century
right and turn of the same 24 years
later and however the the success of
macro theory was immense right because
need that it was used for for a
technology they were little engine in
fact the father of Einstein was building
electric plants in northern Italy he was
working with the maxillofacial well
there would be no podcasts without
electromagnetism and the idea of Maxwell
and Faraday was that there is this field
so recommend is a field so it's a it's
something that is is all over it can
move according to the question that
maxsa wrote and heard I was visualizing
the field as a sort of web of lines
going all over very very fine infinitely
fine sort of and we're immersed in this
field and I Stein realized that gravity
also should be described by field and
gravitational field somehow and he and
he asked himself how to describe this
field and then he got the stroke of
genius
and stroke of genius is that Einstein is
that Newton spacetime and the
gravitational field are actually the
same thing that's that's that's
generativity as I understand it yes in
fact generally it is presented in book
by saying well gravitational field is
nothing else in space-time but I like
better to think it the other way around
space-time nothing else than a
gravitational field the same thing right
when you understand that things are the
same you can say it two different ways
so so Einstein is saying that gravity is
not a thing that lives in space-time
it's a manifestation of the nature of
space-time itself exactly is not what
additional thing lives in space-time is
a manifestation of Newtonian space at
time so this is clear back row
the Newton told us is there is actually
there but this is a gravitational field
the same thing as a gravitational field
which means it can move we can stretch
you can bend and ice I wrote the
question off of the edge and this is a
gravitational wave the black holes on
this thing so that's one ingredient I'm
on board I'm with you so that's the easy
part right we give this great credit to
Einstein in around 1915 or so he finally
put the finishing touches on general
relativity one of the great intellectual
accomplishments of history and part of
that is that it was almost a singular
genius right like Einstein didn't have a
lot of competition while he was doing it
but at the same time as Richard Fineman
famously said you know the day after he
did it
lots of people understood what he had
done like it was a clear thing in some
sense even though it's a different
notion of space-time general relativity
is still within the classical Newtonian
paradigm of physics there's something
space-time it has properties it has
curvature and you can measure it as
precisely as you want and then we come
to quantum mechanics which is a wholly
different thing and why don't you tell
us what quantum mechanics is quantum
mechanics is a thing that's firemen said
the body understands it so that was the
follow up to that quote right right
which means that everybody in the sense
it's but everybody's different manner so
to say quantum mechanics which also owns
a lot to Einstein I says first first who
really understood that it was needed and
made the first steps I I - sending
quantum mechanics it's it's tell us
three things about the world which we
didn't know before and it's sort of the
mathematical representation of these
three things the first thing in my
opinion and I'm not sure I mean the full
majority from this perspective but I
think is crucial is that a lot of things
are discrete it's quantum bantam so the
first thing that is telling us presence
is this electromagnetic field that marks
and Faridah described so well and that
makes the engine torn and makes a radio
work it's actually in some sense made by
little packets which are the photons and
I say the first one who introduced the
notion of photons and now we know that
when light falls on me it actually falls
not as a continuous things but like
little rain it's a granular tick tick
tick tick you look many little photons
there so by the way already I disagree I
think this is great though I mean
certainly it was one of the things that
inspired people to get quantum mechanics
the word quantum write the fact that
classically you have a electromagnetic
wave coming from a light bulb and you
see that as light but experimentally if
you just look at it carefully enough
really really dim light it comes in
packets you see these little you see
these little blobs you don't see
something smooth and then the
interpretive question is which is real
right is it the wave or the particle and
then how they we think about that but
let's not get blog down that quite yet
right right yes in fact I started by
saying this is in my opinion a central
aspect of quantum mechanics but I'm not
sure I'm in the majority here another
way of saying this is that in in up to
quantum up up to quantum mechanics we
thought that we could describe systems
arbitrarily well the state of a system
that will do precision we can measure
position and velocity of a particle or
measure or anything but really well and
that the possible states of the system
possible outcome the measurement error
described beside that which is called
the phase space which is the space of
all possible results and a phase space
the the dimension of the phase space is
action and the core of quantum mechanics
is a constant which is the Planck
constant which has the dimension of an
action which is a little volume in phase
space
I have one degree of freedom the space
of possible states I can think of the
quantum mechanics that there is a sort
of minimal volume into into it so it
forbids us to say things more precisely
about the state of something and this is
compatible this is of a of a sense with
your idea that the essence of quantum
mechanics is this chunkiness there's so
the h-bar the the the the consent of
plank which is a constant that
characterized the quantum phenomena tell
us when were in a quantum Ruggiero and
we're away it's a measure of the
chunkiness of reality in some sense
transforms from the smooth fields of
Faraday to a pixelated does a pixelated
things run of things if it was only that
it would be comprehensible but it's not
only that so there are two more steps
and the second step also is
comprehensible and Shawn I believes you
you might disagree with this as well I'm
ready all right so the second step let
me say in a way that you probably don't
disagree is that we cannot make
predictions about the future quite
fundamentally right not just because we
haven't measured precisely enough not
because we don't know calculations but
if we make everything we can on on on a
physical system and we control it
perfectly and we know it's physics as
best as we can today nevertheless what
we're going to see tomorrow has a margin
of indeterminacy we can make predictions
but there are at best approximate some I
can make it reductions in fact we do
make predictions about the mechanics
allow us to make prediction it's not
that there is no no no particular
possible way around but there is always
some uncertainty that remains which we
can make small but not zero so this is
the famous non determinism of of
quantum mechanics and that's a second
discovery of the world I would say
anything I've phrased it in a way that
you may agree I think if you phrase it
in terms of predictions everyone exactly
again what's going on what's going on
underneath is a different story right
and the third and here we come to the
hardest because so far all right world
pixels and and in predictable is still a
comprehensible world which wouldn't
shock us too much but the third is the
most shocking one and in my opinion the
third discovery of quantum mechanics is
that it described how properties our
system have properties but this
properties in in the light in the
language of the textbook for quantum
mechanics this properties become actual
become real when you measure them now
measuring is it's a nonsense world right
because what what does need to know
about me measure yourself doesn't it
sound like some concept you want this
part so measuring there is and in my
opinion what the theory is telling us is
that property become concrete when two
systems interact and this so far so good
through replacing measurement with
interaction appraise measurement
interacted but to make the machine work
you have to assume that when two system
interact the property of one system
becomes actual with respect to the other
system and not with respect to
everything else and that's at that point
is really shocking that's point is
really shocking now I think if one
accept this idea which is my way of
viewing quantum mechanics which I know
is not the universal way it's not yours
in particular then that's it that's what
quantum mechanics telling us but it's
not so far from mine in that part in the
sense that I am in Eveready and a
believer in the many-worlds
interpretation at least you know I think
that's my favorite I'm happy to change
my mind someday down the
but Everett himself when he invented it
the 1950s when he published his paper he
called it the relative state
interpretation and the point that he was
trying to emphasize was that what you
see is only relative to the things
seeing it this interaction creates an
impression of the measurement outcome
that is intrinsically part of the
relationship between the thing that is
doing the measuring and the thing that
is being observed so I think that
there's you know a some similarity of
words if I shouldn't talk for you but
let me try to second I think what you
would add to what I say is that you want
to take a realist position where beyond
that there is nevertheless a a
deterministic non-relational overall
quantum state of the system that we may
take us the proper description of
reality I would like to say that would
that be so yeah I would I realized I
can't even imagine what it would be like
to be a scientist and not be a realist
about reality right so I would like to
be realist but but less radically so I
mean there are I would say two things
there were a lot of quantities in
physics which are relational we know
that they are the velocity of an object
yes it's not a property of the object
there's no sense in which the lavash is
a probability they'll transform who is
right and in fact this is a good example
because here use measuring but of course
nothing to do measuring right it's a
velocity of object is a property on
orbit respect to another object yes so I
can say that the the earth is that the
velocity with respect to the Sun but the
Sun is not measuring not going out with
meters and kilometers so we use this
language measuring and we turba this
language to say that some properties are
really
I want to be released about relational
properties and I want to think of
reality in a realistic way perhaps a
little bit closer than you to our direct
experience of reality
I see the photons coming in I see the
table being the table I see our direct
experience of reality is tremendously
overrated frankly and I find that if you
want to be really some of the
wavefunction we have actually let me
step back one moment I think given this
strangeness of quantum mechanics anyway
we think it is comes with a price so we
have options we have a number of options
and we have been talking about two
options okay the sort of many-worlds
interpretation in which you have this
wave function of everything which come
with a price or the sort of strictly
relational view which I described which
also come with a price and there are
others and they have their own price
right that's right and the medication
vacations are well which price are we
ready to pay and the price of the
relational interpretation I described is
this weakening of realism so to say what
the state of the system well I don't
know it doesn't matter it doesn't have a
state it only has a state with respect
to its mistake respect to be it is the
same respect to see and there is no
solid objective overall picture the
price of the many-worlds interpretation
is that I have to accept there in some
sense there's always manuals
yes ontology a very heavy ontology and
which price do we want to pay in one way
of the other it contradicts our previous
way of thinking that sure absolutely and
I couldn't agree more about the idea
that there is a price to be paid I could
disagree a little bit about the
heaviness of the ontology that is
associated with many worlds but I think
that the this is a good lesson because
all we need for today's conversation is
the
is the clear fact that we have at the
same time a way to do quantum mechanics
we use quantum mechanics as physicists
everyday it's it's been spectacularly
verified experimentally we know how to
use it we have a recipe we have a black
box and for tequila and we don't have
anything close to an agreement on what
it is what the fundamentals of it really
say so there will be a wonderful thing
to figure out once and for all but maybe
we don't need to do that for the
question of quantizing gravity so just
to put the puzzle the task in
perspective since we grew up while we
human beings as classical people you
know classical mechanics was invented
first it is very intuitive to us even if
pendulums and inclined planes tortured
us as undergraduates we kind of get it
in a fundamental visceral way so we
always start by thinking about systems
from this classical point of view and
then we quantize them we we elevate the
classical description to some quantum
mechanical theory now presumably nature
or God doesn't work that way right
nature just is quantum and and we can
look for classical limits but
nevertheless we poor benighted human
beings given the classical system we
want to quantize it and we have ways of
doing that there are again cookbooks
recipes that work and then you apply
this way to this wonderful thing called
general relativity Einstein's theory of
gravity and we hit roadblocks so this is
why quantum gravity is hard and I guess
roughly around the 1950s would be when
people first started seriously thinking
about it and not till decades later was
any kind of progress really made would
you agree with that yes that's when
people started thinking the first we
realized there was a problem not
surprisingly is Albert Einstein himself
who in 1915 wrote of what we call today
the basic equation of generativity and
one year later in 1916 he wrote a paper
saying well of course this is an
approximation because gravity should be
should have quantum properties
it's quite remarkable because quantum
mechanics we read in textbook yeah that
came out 10 years later invented photon
yeah the idea that things work want a
small-scale in some sense and is a
beautiful page by I Stein in which he
says is an incredible clarity that in
the future his own theory has to be
corrected to take into account of
quantum mechanics and and here we are a
hundred years but you're right this
remained Ellis isolator think there is
some people think about that in the
thirties both in Russian in the and in
the in the West Rosen had a paper we
started studying it but especially
Bronstein motley Bronstein russian yes
russian yes was a friend of London and
he's the first one who figured out that
quantum gravity namely finding the the
quantum property of of the gravitational
field had to imply some radical revision
of space and time and he said it openly
it's a nice story because it comes from
a mistake by Landau for the listeners
Lev Landau Russian physicist one of the
great minds of 20th century physics and
didn't make a lot of mistakes and I was
a big deal right is a big deal in fact
the effect and but you know good
physicists do make mistake I made all
sorts of mistakes best yeah it was best
doing mistakes and getting results maybe
the things go together when when when
quantum mechanics started to be
understood the formalism of mathematics
landau assumed that because of quantum
mechanics it should have been impossible
to measure the value of a field the
electric field in a point and Bohr who's
a big father of
mechanics immediately understood that
this was wrong and it was a longer
discussion and Bohr and Roosevelt wrote
a paper showing that and I was wrong in
London and I recognized that but
Bronstein who was a friend of one now
immediately said well let's do the same
for gravity and their lambda is right
there is a sense in which you cannot
make the measure the gravitational field
in a point because points lose their
meaning and why points lose their
meaning in quantum gravity because the
gravitational field is also space the
gravitational field don't live in space
but it's space itself so in the moment
in which you you look at the quantum
properties of the gravitational field
you're also looking at the quantum
property of a spacetime
of space and one modern way of viewing
what he was doing is a following if you
if you try to pinpoint the position of a
particle in arbitrary small precision
you can but because of quantum mechanics
the velocity of the particle becomes
very indeterminate but the velocity is
also the momentum where the momentum is
also the energy so you have a very large
energy so to say and a very large energy
because of gravity energy is also mass
is MC square so it's like having a large
mass and if you have a large mass in a
small area you create a black hole so
when you try to zoom in in a point very
too small automatically create a little
black hole and if you work out the
numbers you look at the scale and that's
a minimal scale you can look at yes so
quantum gravity sort of asserts itself
when you try to localize things too
carefully in space-time
you know the idea of having a location
seems something that is so intrinsic to
how the world works but I would say and
probably you'll agree
that even today modern researchers who
talk about quantum gravity very often
secretly have in mind some space-time
manifold that has much more reality than
it should according to the rules of
quantum gravity I agree and I would say
that I would have put this way um a lot
of my career has been fighting against
Asia although to be fair
Einstein was on the other side right
yeah I was heartbroken at the at the
prospect that if their work 1/3 of
gravity space-time would lose its
primacy right he really felt and he had
a right you know because he was the boss
of space-time to think that without a
notion of where you were in space if
that were not fundamental he couldn't
quite see how even to do physics but
certainly at the intuitive level it
seems that that is how quantum gravity
should work right so do you think you
know how to quantize gravity let me put
it this way me and my friends good group
of friends in in a few decades we have
put together a tentative set of
equations that can be written on a
single piece of paper which are a a
tentative solution of the problem now do
I hope this to be a quantum theory of
gravity yes I definitely do do I think
it might be quantum security seal of
gravity yes I do
am I sure this is a good quantum theory
of gravity no not at all you don't be
coy you should say with the name of you
theory years
quantum gravity
loop quantum gravity has has been born
from from the early attempts in the 50s
in the 60s that you you mentioned for
the work wheeler the wheat and many
other people but then has evolved into a
more precise mathematical
structure to describe the the quanta of
gravity the this this granular structure
of space-time because in them well what
the photons are for for the
electromagnetic field we think there
should be analogous quanta for for the
gravitational field but that's a
specific characteristic of loop quantum
gravity since the gravitational field
does not live in space-time it's not
it's not something it's not a field in
space-time but its space-time itself the
quanta do not live in space or in
space-time they are themselves
space-time so they should all be
confused with the gravitons which are
sort of a first approximation to the
quantum gravity which are little
particles like photons that move in
space very very very much brothers of
photons the quantum of gravity in in
loop quantum gravity are the the grains
out of which space or the gravitational
field is is built and they are discrete
so they cannot be father cut in smaller
pieces so that pixel granular structure
is right there the pixel grano structure
is right there they at the beginning and
we have a state where Hilbert space I
mean the mathematics of quantum
mechanics are described is this this
pixel space and in the space of our
experience is like the many pixels
seeing from a large distance when you
you don't see anymore the discreteness
like a good high-resolution TV screen
like a high revolution TV screen which
is nice as both and continuous but if
you go very very close so you see the
individual pixels and is there a way to
concisely explain the word loop in the
phrase yes yes first of all it has to
remain a little bit historically now
it's less loopy than at the beginning
but in some sense right oh it's ball ooh
PA Dada
the loop comes from this the the pixels
cells are how would I say they know who
is next to who they know who is next to
who
so one can represent that with links
from loop to loop so you have all these
thoughts linked at one another it forms
a net in fact we call them Network or
more precisely spin network spin because
there is something of the mathematical
spin line in describing it so imagine
this network and if you start from one
of the pixel and go around link link
link link and loop back you make a loop
right so these are loop the loops on
loop quantum gravity and historically
the first mathematical description of
these things that were found were only
single sort of pixels along a loop
individual loops they this is a when Ted
Jacobs on the leaves morning stumbled
upon a solution of the what was
considered the time the main equation of
quantum gravity which is called the
wheeler DeWitt equation and the
solutions depended on loops and so we we
started wondering what are these loops
and and slowly we realized that these
are the quanta this can be soaked as the
individual quanta of space and and in
fact they not don't just loop or not so
linked but there they they can cross so
it's better to think as a network than a
set of loop and I know that at least at
some point in the development of the
theory there's an image of almost like
chain mail in sense there are little
loops that sort of tied around each
other and that gave space it's effective
geometry and reality is that still how
things are thought of now yes yes yes
it's a little less chainmail as before
because the beginning we were we were
working really with little loops and we
were thinking of loops sort of linking
it to one another so I remember some
point I was in Verona and I decided to
to buy a large number of key rings okay
and attached one to the other
a sort of three-dimensional chainmail
this is what I'm remembering good yeah
and then I was was going around today I
gave a talk in Princeton with going with
my chainmail and Joe wheeler was big
grandfather of thinking about when he
saw it it was very excited because he
said yes yes that's how I think about
baseball and he ran away and came with a
copy of his book I didn't know that but
in the in his book there was a picture
that he drew decades before which is a
sort of chainmail I mean so it's
inevitable to mention that once you have
these little one-dimensional loops
it's almost begins to sound like string
theory it because it's our string theory
right because this loops are made by
lines and it's like strings the first
difference with respect to at least two
old string theory to how people started
thinking of string theory at the
beginning is that a string is a closed
string is a little loop but it's a
little loop that moves in space that's
right
while these do not move in space they
make space themselves yes I think that
that's a method core difference the
original difference you see string
theory T's did not grow as a attempt to
solve quantum gravity it came from
another way sort of stumbled on a
possible solution of quantum gravity
which which is a reason for taking it
seriously right is a is the fact that
but it originated from the effort of
making a unified theory of the different
forces and the different pieces of the
standard model and gravity so people who
work in string theory especially at the
beginning
we're not how would I say we're mostly
thinking in a sort of pre general
atavistic way this is space-time and
over space-time there are things that
move and
while loop quantum gravity emerged more
from the the core general relativistic
world where the there's no fix at
spacetime on which things happen base
time itself is something that let me
take let me sort of give my version
because I think it's interesting to
explore this rivalry as it were loop
quantum gravity and string theory safe
to say or the two leading candidates
just in terms of voting by people doing
these yeah in terms of number of people
and like you say loop quantum gravity
arose out of a fairly direct approach to
the question of how to reconcile gravity
in quantum mechanics we knew gravity
Einstein had this theory of general
relativity we have rules for quantizing
things they don't instantly work when
you apply those rules to general
relativity but then you be clever and
people like lee smolin and Ted Jacobson
and Ave ashtekar
gets lots of credit and yourself as well
and you sift through the subtleties here
and you find ways to get a quantum
mechanical theory that really respects
the quantum nature of space-time itself
and this is the goal and you're not
trying to do a theory of everything yeah
also explained until quarks and leptons
right you're not even trying to explain
the possibility of extra dimensions you
think look that I see the three
dimensions of space and the one of time
let's work there and that was the
attitude that was taken where as string
theory as you said started in the
sixties and seventies with this idea
that was originally based on data right
data from the strong interactions of
particle physics the interactions that
keep the quarks inside protons and
neutrons and they saw that certain
particles certain collections of quarks
as we now know them had a relationship
between how fast they were spinning and
how heavy they were and someone said
Veneziano and then Susskind later would
say you know this looks like a
relationship that you would get if they
were little pieces of string that we're
spending and so they developed this idea
called string theory and they were
frustrated because it kept predicting
gravity they didn't want gravity right
that that wasn't their goal and it was
people like John Schwarz my colleague at
Caltech who
he said you know well if gravity exists
maybe if we get a theory of gravity
that's a good thing
everyone laughed you know no one was
really convinced by this and it wasn't
until the 1980s when Schwartz and
Michael Greene showed that string theory
was actually a mathematically consistent
theory that they started saying oh okay
maybe this is real and and not only
potentially a theory of quantum gravity
but also a theory of everything at the
same time many despite the fact that
string theory is by votes the leading
theory of quantum gravity right now
there are many obvious problems with it
one is as I think I'm completely on
board with what you say it's not really
taking the quantum nature of space-time
itself seriously it starts with a string
moving through space time right the
space-time is there already and you can
try to fix that in post production as it
were in close connection but that's a
challenge just as every theory is gonna
have its challenges so that's one
challenge another challenge is that when
you ask okay what does it say about
space-time that a quantum mechanical
string is vibrating in it you find out
that one thing it says is that
space-time is ten dimensional that is
not a feature of the real world
so you say well okay that's a known
problem that we've had in other theories
we can hide these extra dimensions we
can curl them up so they're invisible
but guess what there's more than one way
to do that there is probably an infinite
number of ways to do that at least
numbers are thrown around like ten to
the five hundred different ways of doing
that so your aspiration of getting a
theory that was not only gravity but all
the other forces of nature gets mired in
this ambiguity the fact that we don't
know how to go from the or theory in ten
dimensions down to the four-dimensional
real world so a string theorist would
say look we have this wonderful thing we
have a model where we've been struggling
to quantize gravity and here gravity's
forced upon us from the rules of quantum
mechanics itself we should take
advantage of that of course there's
these issues with ten dimensions and so
forth but hopefully those will be
resolved whereas someone in do quantum
gravity says look I have space-time I
have general relativity I should just
take that seriously at face value try to
quantize it and there are other problems
that come up and you can probably speak
to them as well as I can but then you
would also say and hopefully those
problems will someday be resolved and in
a field where there's not a lot of
direct helpful experimental data because
gravity is a weak force and the world
looks pretty classical to us it's hard
to know which approaches is better a
priori and we have to invest a little
bit of judgment and taste to see which
we like better yes we have to to use
intuition judgment as you say and bet
yeah but I think things are moving
things are moving especially from with
respect to the last thing you said I
agree with everything you said by the
way there is perhaps today less a sense
that we are moving in a in a real
completely detached from from
measurement from experiments not that
there are clear-cut quantum gravity
experiments that choose between theories
certainly not not yet not yet but I
would say it's not so far and there's a
number of things that have happened
recently first of all remember that we
have experiments that have ruled out su5
so which are at a scale which is not
very different for the quantum gravity
scale maybe two or three orders of
magnitude that's right so su5 was this
idea from the 1970s before we were
worrying about quantum gravity was a
particular take on how to unify all the
other forces if you can show without
gravity without gravity so they called
it grand unification it wasn't that
grand also didn't work like you said the
good news was it made explicit
experimental predictions the bad news is
we did the experiment the proton should
decay into lighter particles positrons
and neutrinos and so forth and it hasn't
we've been looking for that in a long
time it hasn't and that's an example in
which there was a measurement at a scale
not so far from
from the scale of quantum gravity but
more recently there have been a number
of empirical results which tell us
something about quantum gravity I
believe one which have not touched
directly I would say neither string
theory nor loop quantum gravity but has
touched pretty strongly a number of
other attempts which that predicted the
violations of Lorentz invariants so
explain what the rents and variances you
explained I can explain what the rent
you know again Einstein would he was
inventing special relativity so he was
before putting gravity into the mix he
was just trying to explain the
symmetries of Maxwell's very successful
electromagnetism and he realized that
what you called space what you called
time was in some sense a choice of an
observer to split four-dimensional
space-time into the three of space and
the one of time and it didn't matter if
you are traveling near the speed of
light
your clock moves differently with
respect to the the clock you left behind
on earth but either choice was fine
there's nothing that you would able be
able to know if you were in a sealed
room you don't know some sort of
absolute velocity that you have with
respect to the universe it's only with
respect to some other part of the
universe
so that's Lorentz invariance Lorentz
invariance is different things moving at
different velocities don't have any way
of telling how fast they're moving in
any absolute sense only with respect to
other things yes which is what we say at
the beginning about velocity being
exactly relational and the fact that was
relational notion was true even before
the rents invariance there's Galilean
invariance which is still true for
Newtonian physics Einstein adds this
ingredient that the way that you divide
up space and time does depend on your
motion through the universe and you can
test this idea you can test it
experimentally right right and so far
seems to be true yes quite spectacularly
correct to this invariance well just
just to show how spectacularly correct
you know
of the predictions of Lorentz invariance
is that if something is moving close to
the speed of light as we said it's
internal clock seems to move at a
different rate than a clock that is
stationary with respect to us so we see
you know here on earth raining down from
the sky these elementary particles
called muons yeah these are part of the
standard model of particle physics a
muon is basically a heavier version of
an electron and you look at how fast
it's moving coming down these are not
created out there in the sky because
they decay muons are not forever they
decay really quickly and in fact they
don't have enough time by our clock to
go from the top of the atmosphere where
they're created in some cosmic ray
collision to reach us down here they
should have decayed away how is it
possible that they don't and the answer
is they're moving so close to the speed
of light that their clock is ticking at
a different rate and this is kind of a
crude but vivid demonstration these days
with high-precision atomic clocks and
other kinds of things we can test this
idea of Lorentz invariance and so far
it's one of the best symmetries that
we've experimentally probe right exactly
thank you
and some tenth attempt to write a
quantum theory of gravity others and
strings and loops constructed some
tentative feels gravity will Lorentz
invariant is broken is violated and
there was a moment in which they
received a lot of attention this this
these other attempts one was called OSHA
of gravity reasons so the people were
excited or maybe we know how to do
quantum gravity but and we can even test
it by looking that Lorentz invariance is
violated right sorry it's an important
point to emphasize that scientists get
thrilled when they can say that in some
subtle way everything we knew before was
wrong right yes very good very good I
think they get too thrilled in fact this
is what happened in that case right
because a lot of people worked on this
idea and a lot of experimenters and
astronomers started to look at
indications
and a program of observations of
Astrophysical phenomena that would
violate Lorentz invariance was lounged
and this was about ten years ago and I
think that now we have quite strong
evidence that Lorentz invariance is not
violated at the scale required the
vitals Thea where you might expect it to
be so a number of attempts to do quantum
gravity has I wouldn't say ruled out
because ruled out is always a bit too
strong but made less convincing less
credible by the fact that what predicted
was not there so that's one example in
which a measurement told something
relevant to quantum gravity a second xmi
three a second example it's very recent
and is with gravitational waves and in
particular the last observation which is
two neutron star falling into one our
spiraling into one hour and merging that
was a few months ago and 17 if I
remember correctly because that was
particular because that was seen by the
gravitational wave detectors but also by
telescopes writer telescopes all sort of
gamma in light waves of light so
everybody saw these things which makes
observation credible first of all you
see a wide variety of instrument it has
to be there but the fantastic thing is
that this is a merger of two neutron
star that happened very far away so the
the light and the gravitational wave
have travelled from there to now for a
very long time
and they arrived at the same moment
within a very small as far as we can
tell I'm sorry we can tell so because of
that we have learned that the rotational
waves end a little netic waves travel at
the same speed and in fact if you if you
put the numbers they travel say speed in
one part in 10 to the 14 or 15 a very
great precision before that so one year
ago
the experimental information the
observation from an empirical
information on the ratio of the speed of
light as the degradation wave was one
part in 10 so in one single stroke we
ameliorated our knowledge or one from
the metal permit of nature by hundred
billion times now why this is this is
great so this product so why this is
great because again a lot of people were
studying modifications of general
relativity that predicted that
gravitational waves go different I give
different speed then then then the
letter magnetic waves so a lot of work
of theoreticians like you and me have
been thrown in the wastebasket just in
one stroke or again maybe made less
credible some less less less interesting
and the third one and I am here perhaps
touching a more controversial thing here
is the non discovery of supersymmetry at
the LHC which was a non news because it
was a non discovery but I think was the
great news at LHC as important as the
discovery of the Higgs that made the the
the title the front page of all
newspapers so when the LHC the big
machine the accelerator of particle
turned on quite quickly so the Higgs
fantastic that was predicted based on
the model but there was a very large
part of the community of theoretical
physicists that expected very strongly
was almost convinced that supersymmetric
particle had to come out and and be seen
supersymmetry being this hypothetical
symmetry that says that particles of
different spin should have friendly
partner particles with difference with
different spin but the same exact
properties so there should be if there's
an electron which we know and love
there's a supersymmetric partner of that
called thus electron
said if there's a cork there are squarks
if there is neutrinos there's neutrinos
etc you should double the number of
particles if supersymmetry is right and
like you say many people thought that it
was right around the corner you would
turn on this machine and squarks and
gluey nose would come popping out at us
we haven't seen anything yet we have not
seen anything yet
and string theory requires supersymmetry
to work and many people expected that
this supersymmetry had to be visible at
the energy of of LHC now when it was not
seeing definitely this does not rule out
string theory at all because string
theory could be the supersymmetry could
be still there but somehow at a higher
energy where we right we haven't seen it
but nevertheless a lot of people were
expecting it and I think if it had been
observed I who I'm not a string guy
would have thought well these people had
the right intuition about nature after
all so maybe these people have a point
for them it wouldn't prove this theory
right but it would be a plus in that
direction I think that's very fair it's
not there was no absolute rockhard
prediction either way but had you seen
supersymmetry your credence and string
theory would have crept up a little bit
exactly you didn't see it therefore
means it better go down exactly exactly
I think this is a this is a point about
how to think about science right we we
often say that we propose theories and
they are falsified by an experiment and
so if a CEO is not falsified it may
still be right but I think things are a
little bit more complicated because we
put credibility in theory and the more
sort of good indirect things happen the
more our credibility goes up and the
more sort of things don't work the
credibility goes down yeah so what is it
should yes so science also worked this
way
so so hinge so indirect thing and so
what I'm saying is that violation of its
symmetry is one the speed of the
gravitation automatic waves is another
one super submit is another one we're
learning you're learning things which
are all relevant toward quantum gravity
and there's also a lot of attention now
in doing toward doing experiments
reality yeah there is one experiment
which is been proposed which I find very
exciting which would not distinguish
between quantum gravity series but would
prove that space is quantized
so that gravity is quantized which has
been proposed by two independent groups
last year or two years ago and in the
I'm very excited about it so I hope it's
real people people would do that soon
and so let me explain it because you
take one particle and sort of nano
particle as more things that people now
know how to work with and you want to
split you put it in a superposition two
positions and you take another particle
and you also quantum split and these two
particles both of we both split are next
to one another so now there is the the
gravitational interaction between the
two so each one is in the Newtonian
field of the other so when we say nano
particles this is not an elementary
particle like an electron it's like a
little motive dust it's a small test
it's a small grain of dust right and
these we we not we then are able to to
put it just quantum superposition of two
different positions so you have two
particle both of them in in a
superposition next one another so each
one of them feels the gravitational
force of the the two brand
just in which the other one is and
because of that the state of the to
particle gets entangled and now there
are very clean ways to see if two things
are entangled yes and if they are in if
we find that they're entangled and this
is true quantum entanglement it's one so
it's not just they're related but
they're know if this happen it means
that the gravitational field itself was
in a superposition but off to different
wasn't to branches so to say and since
the gravitational field we know is
space-time it means that space-time can
be put in a superposition and this is a
proposed experiment this is a proposed
experiment but if you work out the
numbers the people who manipulate these
small particles they say that they think
they should be able to do it in a in a
few years and I think it would be
wonderful because there are still people
around even if a minority who says I
don't believe that space-time it has a
quantum properties I've met them yes and
because come on space-time space-time is
a heavy thing and this experiment if you
can be done would be spot a a clear
indication that you can put that there
is this in determination this this is
performed quantum nature also of space
itself so I'm about halfway through the
number of things I wanted to talk about
but we need to go and be good conference
participants but let me close I have two
questions that I would like to least
throw out there and the first one
there'll be a temptation talk about it
for half an hour but let's not
there's loop quantum gravity there's
string theory there are other approaches
causal set theory and Euclidean quantum
gravity and so forth
quantum gravity we don't have a
consensus we're trying different things
but nevertheless we live in a world
where there are finite resources to do
science
academic positions grant money prizes
and so forth glory there's a feeling
that certainly been put forward that
there's been unfairness in how the
representation of these different
approaches to quantum gravity has been
distributed throughout academia in
particular that the string theorists
have kind of a dominant position that
maybe they don't deserve given that
string theory hasn't really predicted
anything definite that we've tested it's
mathematically very beautiful but
there's obstacles to it like like there
are two other theories I personally
think that string theory has a good
reason to be the leading candidate but I
also think that it would be very healthy
for the field to be doing various other
things so what are your feelings about
the fairness is the free market of ideas
working well here or is there or should
we are we not being quite fair enough to
this diversity of different approaches
yes you invited me to yes I think that
if I look back a couple of decades the
distribution of resources has not been
fair with let me say it clearly we
thought respect and an appreciation for
string theory this is not far from me
for saying that string theory should
have be found it should be thrown out of
university or anything like that it's a
it's a wonderful research direction but
it's a research direction is not a
established result that we can take for
granted and as a research direction it
might be right might be wrong it may be
partially right partly wrong and so on
and I think that other approaches the
loop code gravity in particular has
suffered because of a dominance of
string theory there is a there is a a no
linearity there is a bandwagon effect
that I mean powerful people are in power
of positions and do one thing and it
would not be the first time in the
history of science in which
a group of people a large group of
people dominate and and and push the
field in a direction which is not useful
it could it could be so I think a little
bit more fairness and being more
free-market fair I think maybe we
alluded to this but didn't become clear
any approach to quantum gravity or any
other unsolved puzzle and physics has
this element of taste around it in the
sense that you will be making some
sacrifices right like some things in a
certain approach work and are very nice
and natural and other things seem
problematic and different people have
different judgments as to say well this
is a problem but surely we will overcome
that we've got more than 40 years of
work and so string theory clearly has a
problem connecting from this purported
10 dimensional reality down to our four
dimensional reality do you want to
mention some of the problems that loop
quantum gravity has well yes I think
that the in the version in which we're
working today the work in the covariant
version of quantum gravity at least
there is and this is a plus a a well
defined set of equations ok so right now
say this is the theory now we don't know
really if this is consistent in the
sense and in the precise sense we can
use it sort of order by order to give to
compute but we don't know if this if
this converges in any sense so even in
the weakest possible sense we don't know
if going to next order this thing it
doesn't go fully this is one of those
famous things in quantum theories where
you might calculate a good approximation
but then you try to make your
approximation better and everything
blows up and everything close up right
right so since this is not being proved
this has not been checked there aren't
even sort of good indications for
believing so this is definitely a weak a
weakness of the theory on the theory
could blow up still and be meaningless
however I think that the what we need is
not more mocking mathematics we need to
apply this theory to reality
I'm working on the application to black
holes I'm trying is trying to connect
loop quantum gravity to Astro physics
cosmology see if you can say something
for no dark matter fast radio bursts
gamma ray signals signatures in the
cosmic background radiation because at
the end of the day what will convince us
that one thing is good or not is not in
my opinion the mathematical cleanness
now we don't get it some days that they
might be a while before it comes but you
have to explain the data yeah you have
to explain the data so in the moment in
which say look I have a I like this
prediction or expression of the data and
it works well then the the the attention
of community community will focus on
that let let me say about the the the
string theory that things have changed
with respect to some time ago I mean I
think there have been there is much more
reciprocal respect than ten years ago I
think
there was a moment in which strings so
we had very high hopes and was sort of
saying we we have it it has a cracked a
little big hopes were always high there
were hopes for a quick resolution right
I would say there was a moment in which
people thought okay now we're going to
compute all the parameters standard
model now we're gonna do this and this
and that we're gonna see see missing
supersymmetry and we're going to
understand dark matter because dark
matter is just a neutrally you know
whatever whole thing will come together
and think some more difficult nature is
subtle and occasionally malicious so the
the idea of oh we are there it's it's a
bit poor far away people step back which
means also there's more more respect
people are I talked to string theories
more than before and there is exchange
obviously we can learn from one another
right because that's the ways physics
world well and maybe this feeds into the
answer to my final question which is
predict the future well what do you
see coming in the next 10 or 20 years
and among those things do you see
convergence between different attempts
to think about quantum gravity or do you
see more diversity with more things
coming or do you think that someone's
just going to get the right answer and
everyone will agree I don't know no it's
a making prediction is always difficult
especially about the future I don't know
I think that it would be great to think
that there's convergence but in the
history of science there have been huge
debates huge disagreements no it's not
well in a particular special situation
all right if you look back at the
history of science always being very
opposite theories Fuji stories and so
many others all right and usually one of
the two sites are not be right they're
not be wrong and often it took long it
took long I get to get clarity I what I
hope and I would like to see that this
is whatever happened is that I know we
can compute a black hole tunnel into
white hole and recognize that some
signals are exactly that and then we
have a clear grasp on on something which
is happening and so and so we will see
that this is the right direction so
gravity is out there in the universe
quantum mechanics is out there in the
universe it's not completely unrealistic
to imagine that somehow it will show up
yes I I do expect it will show up
somehow however much it seems much
closer today that it seemed twenty years
ago
all right that's a great place to stop
Carl oh thank you so much for coming
thank you sure thanks a lot
[Music]
you
[Music]